I want to bring in ha Helia now he's a
senior associate fellow in International
Security studies at the Royal United
Services Institute and Carnegie
Endowment for International Peace he
joins us live from London a very warm
welcome to you so in the past hour or so
this all important resolution has been
past the United Nations the question now
is implementation given that Israel has
a track record and ignoring what the UN
has to
say so I think that the issue that we
all have to keep in mind is that the
Israelis will change course as a result
of one of two things one if it
domestically they feel that they have
accomplished what they have set out to
accomplish and they choose of their own
valtion or if they are forced to do so
as a result of pressure not from the
United Nations not from the
International Community but from
Washington DC and Washington DC hither
to until now has not placed that
requisite amount of pressure in order
for that result to come about and I
don't think that we are going to see any
change in isra Behavior with regards to
Gaza or otherwise unless that changes in
Washington first it also seems pretty
clear that if there is going to be any
lasting change there needs to be some
fresh thinking and a fresh change of
leadership in Israel but of course that
isn't likely to come anytime immediately
soon what happens in the
interim in the interim I think you
unfortunately see more of the same where
there is no Clarity over Israel's game
plan in Gaza where there's no clarity
about the quote unquote day after in
Gaza on the contrary you have
contradictory messages being put out um
and and this is causing a great deal of
concern and and frankly consternation in
Washington DC as well as of course in
other capitals where they they want to
be able to give sucker to Israel
in this particular time um but even
Israel's supporters in places like
Washington are kind of stuck because
they want to see a game plan they want
to see a strategy that makes sense not
sort of wild fancy ideas about um
eliminating Hamas from the face of the
Earth or something they want to see
actual concrete objectives and ones that
do not simply mean we bomb we bomb we
keep on bombing and then we'll figure it
out later just just talking about um
those apparent military objectives that
strategy that Israel may or may not be
going for I'm just wondering to what
extent alifer Hospital factors into all
of that we've heard within the last few
hours claims that guns ammunition
grenades and flat jackets have been
found at the hospital of course Israel
is inde we can't independently verify
that it's only Israel on its own making
those claims I wonder what all of this
means within the context of our
understanding of the
conflict I don't think it frankly means
very much because as you said we are
unable to verify any of this it would
not surprise me if they found such
materials it would also not surprise me
if they didn't um and we've already seen
unfortunately far too many occurrences
um not just in the last day but in the
last few weeks where a claim has been
made about for example finding evidence
of uh of hostages being held in this
particular room this was you know over
the last few days um and the evidence
turns out to be a calendar with the
names of the week written in Arabic um
not names of people who are actually
involved in the hostage taking so and
there's there's quite a few other
examples that look similar to that so
unfortunately unless there is a
third-party verification of this sort of
thing it becomes very difficult for
people then to read into it um right now
there's talk about I I saw this just
before I came on air where an idea F
spokesperson I think said oh look they
they taped over cameras so this is proof
of something if Hamas had taken over the
hospital they would need to tape over
cameras they simply switch them off okay
so I mean that it becomes very difficult
and unfortunately what we've seen
regularly over the last few weeks um uh
in in various directions is not just
misinformation but active disinformation
about different things that are
happening um and it becomes very
difficult then for people to verify
what's actually going on yeah there is
indeed a blizzard of information and
disinformation HJ Helia from the
Carnegie Endowment for International
Peace thanks for joining
us thank you